this is a production of Cornell
University
I'd like to introduce Jose Vargas he
comes to us from Costa Rica where he
studied at the University of Costa Rica
he contacted me about six years ago and
after a number of communications he was
admitted and here he is um I asked Jose
to work on a number of virus projects I
should preface that by saying he he's
wanted to come here to pursue interests
in biology and bioinformatics so he
worked on a number of virus systems I
asked him to set up a system to allow us
to use large-scale sequencing
technologies for Diagnostics he has done
that over the last few years
additionally he's making uses the same
technologies to address some questions
regarding the host response the smaller
a response to virus infection and today
he'll be talking about the
bioinformatics efforts he's made to
analyze networks of small RNAs in the
interest of time he will not be
discussing much about the biology per se
but the best is still to come so with
that as an introduction Jose okay yep
okay I think you'll for coming I was
very happy to have the opportunity to
tell you about what I've been doing for
the last five years or so so excuse
mention I've sort of been involved in
two different lines of research on the
one hand we've been looking we've been
conducting products that involve virus
and virus detection and characterization
and this involves all the published
works so far and even though I've taken
some time I only have one slide to show
for today which is a summary of what we
publish you can see here we've been
working on
spinach latent virus of tomato we've
also work on to viral grade by virus
Grapevine virus II and great band
asteroid mistake associated virus and
also one viroid in Grapevine
and that's it for pathology now I'm
gonna move through my main thesis
project I'm sorry about that
where we are focusing on the question
this is the question we're focusing on
what is the role of small RNA mediated
regulatory networks in host virus
interactions so just to get it out there
I'm gonna show you my objectives they
may not make full sense right now but
hopefully through the interaction
through the interaction they will I just
want you to know where I'm going so I
have two objectives what I want to do is
to identify and describe biologically
relevant small RNA mediated regulatory
networks and once I have them to
determine the regulatory contribution of
the resulting networks now going back to
my main questions there are three teams
here that I would like to address small
RNAs networks and host virus
interactions and I'll start with the
interactions so when you think about a
virus some may think about this but this
is you see it yeah this is actually a
variant a very own is an infectious
particle a virus is better thought of as
an infective cell where you have a whole
complement of proteins that are not
present in the variant but are required
for to complete the virus replication
cycle so the viruses as you know they
hijack the cell metabolism
therefore they interact at many levels
with their host today I'm going to be
focusing in a series of interactions
involved in immune responses so in this
diagram here I'm showing the virus
replication cycle from virus entry
genome decap sedation viral replication
and synthesis viral proteins and on the
Left I'm showing a diagram that is
familiar to most people here where viral
products can be recognized by pattern
recognition receptors in the case of
plant viruses there would be
intracellular and they can trigger a PGI
base response I suspected virus encode
effectors that can block the pti
response and consequently
the hose has evolved resistance genes
that can recognize these viral proteins
and trigger an epi response this is
quite common female pathology now in
viruses there's also but we think it's
something we think of us adaptive
immunity where viral products can be
recognized by its host protein to launch
an adaptive immune response that is
affected by RNA I or RNA interference
now so the main takeaway here is that
RNA interference is involved in
antiviral defense and just as a reminder
RNA interference RNA AI or RNA silencing
refers to multiple biogenesis pathways
that I've shown here in boxes the lead
to the production of small RNAs which
are molecules of 21 to 24 nucleotides
long
that are involved in transcriptional
translational or process scription or
regulation and they're quite important
they've been even people like to call
the master regulators and their activity
has been described in multiple cellular
systems and in multiple settler
processes in various systems here I'm
showing examples where Micronesia refers
to as massive regulators in humans plans
and drosophila so white flies and in
these systems have been related to
regulation in cancer development for our
cases plan defense response is quite
important and also gene immiscibility
now small rnas are also in discovering
plans to act through regulatory networks
again I'm showing here several examples
that show
smaller networks involved in development
trade dominance in overall gene
expression so hopefully at this point of
convince you that this small rnas are
quite important regulators and that they
collectively form regulatory networks
involved in multiple processes like
defense development stress now if we go
back to this plot I would like to
point this set of proteins years that
are known as viral silencing suppressors
so these are proteins encoded in the
virus that are able to block RNA i or
RNA interference so when you think when
you remember I just sort of went through
the relevance of RNA interference for
regular cell metabolism and viruses
interference could have a great effect
and in fact I don't have the time today
to tell you mechanistically how this
occurred but the viruses of suppressors
can act by interfering with the small
RNA biogenesis they can also sequestered
these molecules making them unavailable
for their action and they can also
interfere with the proteins involved in
the pathways now to remember that the
pathways involved in antiviral refunds
defense and regular cell metabolisms
have a lot of common factors so this
viral interference could have a great
effect on the plant and we I'm gonna
show one example here where I'm showing
our ovide of these plants expressing
well transgenic be expressed in
different viral silencing suppressors
from different viruses so on the left
this is how a healthy plant would look
and this are not virus infected plants
they're only expressing this virus
suppressor proteins and you can see that
the effect is quite dramatic so
something that if could be of interest
is that financing suppressors are not
exclusive to viruses there are also
known examples in bacterial pathogen
pseudomonas syringae is well study model
where we've some of the proteins have
been described or involved in silencing
suppressor also there's a known amaizing
pathogen bite after SOG that encodes
what appears to be multiple silencing
suppressors so this convergence appears
to indicate that the small RNA silencing
could be a play a very relevant role in
plan defense now with this in mind and
thinking that small Ernest or master
regulators of defense
and that they've worked through
regulatory networks we developed this
main research questions number one what
is the role of small RNA mediated
networks in immunity for our purposes
viral infection and given the existence
of these common factors between smaller
Naevia Genesis and defense you also have
the next question which is what is the
effect of viral silencing suppressors in
hos small RNA mediated regulatory
networks now to study this our model is
kokuboro mosaic virus or CMV here I'm
showing a diagram of his genome there's
three rnas and over here this earth to B
corresponds to the protein that is
involved in the Health Sciences
suppressor activity so we've developed a
couple of mutants for this protein and
we infected are available sister Lyanna
plans so here I'm showing the phenotypes
after three weeks or three weeks post
inoculation on the top we have to mark
plan so this should be uninfected second
name corresponds to clients infected
with a wild-type version of CMV and then
the two lower panels corresponds to
trans infected with the mutated version
of this virus and you can see they're
pretty much asymptomatic now in case you
were wondering we do know that the virus
is replicating because we can detect the
coat protein in all plants and just as a
controlled we do not detect the sinus
repressor protein in our mutants as
expected now this is our experimental
system now let's just I'm gonna go back
and review what we know about smaller
and a revelatory networks in a bit more
detail and just to get our terms right a
network is a set of nodes connected by a
set of edges in here I'm showing the
nodes in blue which for my presentation
corresponds to RNAs can be smaller nasal
transcripts and the green corresponds to
the edges that in my case corresponds to
the interaction between the nodes I've
already shown that they're involved in
multiple processes and now most of these
networks are composed by
pairs of micro RNA and face small RNA
interfering RNAs now what do I mean by
that
here I'm showing the biogenesis pathway
for micro rna's so they are expressed
from a gene the transcript is processed
by dice or like proteins into smaller
neighs they're then sorted and loaded
into a go containing complexes and this
complexes are the effector molecules
that will lead to mRNA degradation or
translational repression now in some
cases there's a different outcome the
micro RNA will target a transcript and
instead of leaving leading to cleavage
it leads to the production of
double-stranded RNA that is then cleaved
by dicing like proteins to produce phase
small RNAs now it's not really evidence
in the diagram here but the named phase
small RNAs refers to the fact that these
double stranded RNAs are cleave
sequentially by decisive produce to
produce smaller anaise in tandem there
are 21 nucleotides long
now these small RNAs are also loaded
into other containing complexes that can
then have an effect on a regulatory
effect on their targets now I'm going to
translate this diagram into a network
view and again here we have two micro
nice they can target transcripts lead to
degradation sometimes they will lead to
the production of face smaller nice or
fuzzy RNAs and this some have no
activity some can target order
transcripts some can even target its own
transcript or lead to secondary
production of small RNAs so this creates
a cascade effect where the amount of
information carry for the initial
molecule grows very quickly now again to
go back to the terms in this case my
molecules here corresponds to the nodes
and the edges are the interactions
between these molecules back to
review we have a very well study example
in a cascade that initiates with micro
RNA 173 and smaller nays that derive
from it but then I'm going to go through
in some detail because I'm going to use
it as an example and control later on so
if you have heard of it if you know it
near 173 was described about ten years
ago and it leads to this cascade of
Tassie RNAs
Tasi rnase refers to transact in small
interfering RNAs which was just a first
class of face-it small interfering RNAs
so tasse is a subset of fatty RNAs
just in case it can be confusing now in
this diagram what I'm showing it's
transcripts in blue ovals and small RNAs
in orange rectangles so there's an
initial transcripts that give rise to
mature micro RNA targets that test to
transcripts to produce in this case
they're actually several small RNAs I'm
just showing one that it's a particular
interest because it targets another gene
but it also leads to the production of
secondary RNAs that can then go on and
target others transcripts this is an
example of how this cascade effect would
work now over the years this cascade has
been growing and this could represent
one of the more recent views of how this
may work now
I'm showing a similar structure so we
have a micro RNA here in the middle set
targets in this case for low side which
are in the middle of these clusters that
produce fuzzy RNAs which are the little
balls around each cluster now this was a
very nice study because they were able
to link this regulatory cascade to
metabolic stress which provide
functionality for it
now I must say that their analysis is
restricted to a known class of
micronation classes so we knew about
these interactions they just expanded on
them
and then they performed by informatica
target prediction for all this small RNA
and performed target violation on a few
selected targets of interest so they not
doing a whole genome-wide study they're
just looking at a particular cascade of
interest
now there is one precedent of a genome
wide view of regulatory networks by
small RNAs which was performed by David
Balkans group around 2010 and where they
are looking from a genome-wide
perspective and they provided the
initial description of smaller na
mediated networks they did some
structured analysis they were thinking
about it from a network's point of view
and it's a really nice paper which
reflects the overall potential of this
regulatory networks but we can really
assess the biological significance of it
because they did not account for
different types of small RNAs and the
fact that most of them that you find in
a library are not active and they did
not do any validation for their edges
it's all bioinformatics or acidic
prediction so with this in mind and
going back to my main question of what
is the role of small RNA mediated
networks in immunity when thinking about
how to conduct this project and what we
need I came up with a set of
requirements for the network's that we
would use or a reference frame to study
that should be biologically relevant it
should be experimental support for it
should be reproductive or reproducible
and when going down the list and
thinking about what's known so far we
realize we don't have an appropriate
framework to do this comparison so
unfortunately we don't have enough
information to address this question and
at this point we decided well we could
try something else or we can do it
ourselves so coming up we
reference frame to study small RNA
regulation became a main thesis project
which was to produce a model network of
small RNA interactions now admittedly I
did not have a background and program in
a computational biology at the time but
it was a pretty smooth process I don't
know why people complain a lot it was
mostly inconsequential it seemed to just
go right there's no problem to it so
I'll go back to my objectives as sqeeze
mentioned my objectives will reflect the
fact that the part with virology it's
over at this point of the presentation
if you were hoping to hear more about
viruses please wait until the next time
because by now I'm going to focus on the
networks and mostly I'm gonna focus on
identifying and describing biologically
relevant small RNA mediated networks and
determining the regulatory contribution
then again this is to provide a
reference frame so that we can go back
to study the effect of virus in these
systems
now I'm gonna first describe the
approach I took to identify this smaller
in a mediated networks so step one is to
produce a model network for a lab adopts
italiana the model network with I then
will involve identifying all nodes and
known and all edges once we have this
basically have a map of all possible
interactions using this reference frame
we can then input expression data to
produce sample or treatment specific
networks so that's the plan now to do
this if I go back to my diagram of
components because we're working at our
top sister Lyanna we know a lot or
there's a lot of background information
so the latest annotation of our adop's
is enum is named arab port 11 and it was
produced in 2016 last year and from here
we can get all known microRNAs and
target transcripts it's a pretty full
annotation and for the rest of the
molecules i had to come up with a by
informatics tool and a few data sets to
get all
information I'll get into the details of
the Davises in a minute now slice for
phase 1 for phase 2 then we need which
phase 2 is a quantification part we
would use smaller and AC you can only
seek to count or provide a quantum I
quantitative side to it now for data at
position if you remember I need three
type of data I'm trying to get small
RNAs which are produced by a small RNA
seek RNA seek to get all the transcripts
information I'll describe the rhythm
datasets in a minute now to obtain all
these molecules or these data sets we as
I mentioned before we have an experiment
with our adopts italiana from which we
get total RNA and from that total RNA
sample we produce these three datasets
now hopefully the first two are familiar
I'll take a minute to describe take a
some library because actually quite
important for the purposes of this
presentation so Dagenham library or
taking up data is what we use to
validate our edges which are the
interactions between small rnas and
transcripts and it's a two-step process
we first do a projection of all the
cleavage sites
now here I'm Illustrated a messenger RNA
we find regions where small RNAs can
target and use because we know how they
act we can predict how a cleavage
transcript would look then we move on to
experimental validation we're using
molecular methods we clone and sequence
all degraded RNAs and then we look for
accumulation of five prime terminal tax
of these sequences at the predicted
cleavage site which basically means we
look at our sequencing data and
determine if we can find molecules that
would fit our prediction now the
validation process or how we examine
this result is a I don't really have
time to describe it in full but it's a
process is a quantitative assessment
that involves statistical model so the
take-home message is that we have
experimental validation for all of the
edges interactions
networks that I'm going to present and
also we do this so we can sort of
network has that we can do biologically
relevant inferences from n networks now
just to remind you because this is gonna
be important and I'm gonna go back and
forth between these terms when I talk
about decadal data I'm talking about
experimental validation of smaller
nativist of a transcript which in our
networks corresponds to the edges now
just a quick comment about the data
acquisition we make our own libraries in
the lab in case someone is interested in
this for RNA seek is the only one where
we use a kid but we still make them in
the lab and the other two data sets are
produced by somehow hybrid methodologies
from ginger man on his lab in our
publications that we've adapted to her
on that now for the bioinformatics tool
when I was thinking about how to present
this I was reminded about this Italian
researcher the Davis seminar in the fun
biology seminar seminar serious a couple
of weeks ago and she had a great comment
and I quote she said that when
describing your buying formatic
pipelines to your colleagues it's like
showing pictures on your kids to your
friends no one cares even though you
want to show them every detail and you
think you're writing a symphony it's
just I don't know I think someone may
care and if you do I'm happy to tell you
about it but I'm just gonna summarize my
tool in one slide I made this by
informatics Python or tool that has
several modules that are made to find
all the nodes in my networks and I'm
making use of existing tools I've also
modified some of them and I created my
own and the same strategy for the edges
so then my tool breaks all the notes and
I just together to produce my smaller
and a regulatory networks so that wasn't
too painful I hope now another reminder
when looking for all analyzing my data
and trying to identify all the
components in my networks remember I'm
trying to produce
Network which involves all nodes or
small rnas and transcripts and all edges
in this process I realized that the
identification is data intensive and
most importantly the identification
depends on expression and the expression
of the small rnas could depend on
developmental stages the tissue type you
used to make your collection or
environmental cues such as stress so to
account for this I produce my own data
sets and also went back to databases so
this is a summary of the data use for
small RNA libraries I made 14 smaller
than any libraries from a reveal of 6
plants that were infected or not with
CMV and also I got 38 data sets
available at the NCBI database that
corresponds to wild-type arrival of
these plants and this was very useful
because there are drops is there's a lot
of background information and I was able
to find datasets corresponding to just
wall type healthy plants also hormone
treated and I've shown an example of
metabolic stress I've also have
libraries from different tissue sources
and also plants have been challenged by
pathogens including viruses and
nematodes now for the diadem libraries I
had the same strategy oh I produce 16
data sets but they're only 5 available
at NCBI and they corresponds to in
fluorescence and season Institute's now
ok so that is the setup let's take a
look at the results just to remind you
I'm trying to identify these networks or
smaller in a regulatory networks and
from my diagram the missing components
are the fuzzy low side that corresponds
to the transcripts that produce fancy
rnas which are the other missing parts
so the identification of these
components is performed using smaller
names information and this is a summary
of all the libraries that I use so in
the
x-axis is the name of the library the
identification for the library that said
on the Left corresponds to this study or
the ones I produced oh and the y axis
corresponds to millions of reads then in
black I'm showing the total yield of the
sequencing project when available in
blue I'm showing the imaan of all the
reads are actually usable or pass filter
and what I'm trying to communicate here
is that the libraries are varied right
some are really good some are not
they're hard to evaluate so we take that
into account in our analysis now to find
those fancy low so which is the first
step I took each library and tried to
identify these regions using an existing
tool called face tank and the idea is
that I identified all the regions in all
my libraries and then I summarized the
results to produce a consensus fuzzy
locus and these are the results again so
here what I'm showing is fuzzy low side
detection so regions that produce face
small rnas libraries are on the x axis
and on the y axis is the number of
detection events so how many fancy Lassa
I detect per library and you can see
again the results are varied and
actually our libraries were pretty good
for detecting facil also you can see
some just provided no results at all now
the next step is to produce a consensus
low side so here is a summary which
basically represents repeatability how
many times a region is found to be a
producer of a CRNAs across libraries I
found 92 regions represented here in the
x-axis in the y axis is the number of
times that region is recognized across
libraries and you can see that most of
them or a good amount of them are found
multiple times but some have found in a
very few occasions even just one time or
in one in a single library and this
could represent false positives or they
cross so just
percent regions that are expressed only
under a particular circumstance
now she remember my diagram Vasilisa are
the regions that produce a small rnas
and we can test the activity of the
small rnas using Tegaderm data so I use
this to validate this previous set of
results by asking the question do the
small RNAs that derive from this loss I
have biological activity assessed by
Dagenham data and now I have this
reduced subset of fifty regions from
which I have from which smaller nice
they're smaller nice derive from them
actually have value-added targets and if
you're wondering where are they or what
they are
most of them corresponds to annotated
regions in the genome that correspond to
coding genes and for our purposes
they're of great interest because a lot
of defense related genes are known to
produce small RNAs so the most evident
example is mvlr proteins that we know
they're transcripts can produce phase
small interfering RNAs and actually this
is why I was mentioning before that
they're known as massive regulators of
land defense now going back to our
diagram so we have the consensus locus
we map the small rnas and now we need to
find the triggers and just a quick
reminder about what a trigger is a
trigger will represent the smaller RNA
that stars this process of
double-stranded RNA production in
subsequent cleavage now in this diagram
I must say this is not entirely accurate
and very quickly I will show you a few
interesting features about small RNA or
fatty RNA biogenesis that are usually
not accounted for so going back to my
mere 173 example we know it targets the
task 1 transcript leads to the
production of small rnas and this would
be the expected result the micro RNA
sets the register for the cleavage
ribbit now this most models are based on
21 nucleotide long face is more
interfering RNAs I don't have time to
show you the evidence but we know there
are actually also 22 nucleotides long
and small RNAs and if you think about it
this is relevant because if you change
the size for one of these molecules then
everything has shifted over and another
important feature is that per transcript
there can be multiple triggers as I'm
showing here and those triggers can
actually set up different registers from
which new small RNAs can arise and this
small RNAs can have possible new targets
and therefore new activities and it
overall represents an unexplored
standard regulatory capacity for this
for each of these locusts so then going
back to my process I'm trying to find
the triggers that set up the production
of phases small interfering RNAs and
this is a summary for 74% of all my
transcripts I was able to find a trigger
there's 36% for which I couldn't
identify any and you can see here in
some cases I was able to find out down
to three triggers per transcript now
having this trigger information and just
remind you the relevance of the triggers
is that they can set up different
registers from which new RNAs can arise
we can now collect all the small RNAs
that derive from the different register
and different sizes that I mentioned who
make a big pool including micro RNAs and
use our daggers on data to confirm them
so here I'm showing a brief summary of
the decade on data in red this is what
was what exists in the NCBI data
database in black I'm showing our
contributions so we made 16 extra
libraries which can be summarized here
where for this analysis we 89% of all
the information or all the decadent data
use corresponds to our libraries
and if you remember this is what we use
to validate the interactions between
smaller nascent transcripts so when we
do that for our big pool of small rnas
we get this results we know we have two
classes of small rnas microRNAs which
I'm using unknown set this was
describing the latest annotation of
Arabidopsis we know there's 427 micro
RNAs reported I was able to find
activity or confirm activity for 223
which corresponds to the most
comprehensive analysis of small RNA or
micro RNA activity in avid ops excuse
integral Dom data now this is where the
my main contribution of the main
contribution of my tool is in finding
all these fancy RNAs and in particularly
the ones that are active which I'm
showing here in red now I'm going to
focus on this active set of fatty RNAs
and break them down into four groups the
first group corresponds to 21 phase
small RNAs which kind of correspond to
this blue set here and this corresponds
to the small RNAs that most available
tools would find which are about 350 but
then there's about 250 of these active
small RNAs there are in a different
register than my tool is able to pick up
additionally there's also about 150
which are 22 nucleotides long that on
this most tools will not pick up unless
we do a combined search and there's a
subset where they're both 22 and in a
different register now again to
summarize this what I'm saying is that
using this approach we were able to
double the number of small RNAs of known
activity therefore we expanded on the
regulatory capacity we can recover now
we've gone through pretty much all the
motions all we have to do now is remove
all known active small rnas and attach
it all together to produce a model
network and four year later this is my
small RNA regulatory network it
this is what I was being working for now
a quick reminder I am using decagon data
for this I know I keep saying it but so
the interactions all the edges have
experimental support but even so I think
whenever at least whenever I'm
confronted to something like this
a few questions arise it's it real right
hopefully I convince you that it is
because I'm using experimental or each
interaction is experimental validated
does it reflect biology I'll try to
evaluate that and most importantly as
you may have noticed I don't have
sufficient jokes for the length of this
seminar so if you have any suggestion
and you're heading forward by now I
really would need I don't know any
network jokes but no no stay there we
think about it so far but I mean showing
it's all the steps to lead to the
production of the networks so we're just
building to this moment now I get it's
the fun part and in this I only have a
few more things to say now just a quick
reminder the objectives were to describe
and identify and describe biologically
relevant small RNA mediating networks
now to show that they actually valid I'm
gonna sort of go into that Network to
our old friend mu 173 which I've said
before we know a lot about it and if my
network instruction is correct I should
be able to reconstruct what we know
about Mir 173 so I'm going to use this
cascade for evaluation quick reminder
I'm also using this because the tricky
one there's a lot of nuances we know it
targets the test transcripts for this
transcript in specific there's three
triggers we know this phase changes so
there's a lot of things going on and
this would be the most challenging
example and just to guide you we have a
micro RNA we have for fuzzy low side in
the middle of these clusters the balls
around corresponds to sets of small rnas
at the right from it we know it will
target their predicted to target PPR
proteins which are proteins involved in
defense and
is also a function for this which is
been shown to be involved in metabolic
stress so I'll try to recreate that so I
go to my network I tried to get the mere
173 sub Network represented here or
highlight in red and I'll change the
view to something more simple so just a
reconstructed we have one mic Rene you
have four transcripts and a set of low
sign so so far so good
now I'm going to show oh so here they
did my informatics predictions of
targets right I've been saying how I do
experimental validation of targets so
now I'm going to change the view and
show you the results for this with my
tool and there's a couple of things to
mention here the change of colors the
blue ones the new ones are all these
small RNAs there are different sizes are
in a different register so they're here
to illustrate the contribution of
including all these different nuances
into an analysis tool and on the bottom
I'm showing all the RNA transcript
targets and here hopefully you can see
it I'm showing the PPR proteins are they
predicted and validated to be targets so
we can reconstruct the network with the
right topology we have the right
molecules now they have a function they
know it is involved in metabolic stress
so I took all the genes that are
targeted by this cascade and did a
functional enrichment analysis using
gold terms so I'm gonna use several this
plot so let me walk you through it in
this case the size of the circle
corresponds to the breast of the
category so for example biological
process is a much bigger category than
transport then white means non
significant enrichment everything in
color refers to significantly enriched
categories and the darker the more
significant the results now before you
go through it I'm just gonna direct you
to this side over here which corresponds
to categories involved in defense
response more importantly to abiotic
stress stimulus so what I'm showing here
is that using my approach and go region
functional enrichment we could
make functionally valid inferences from
our network I was able to reconstruct or
validate my network because we have to
write the polity we have to write
molecules and we can even predict the
right functions using this approach
summarized here so again we have
accurate identification of the
components we have accurate
reconstruction of the network topology
you can make functional inferences that
are consistent with experimental results
I've shown how we can expand on the
regulatory capacity and just to remind
you we use an unbiased genome-wide
approach right we're not focusing on our
particular sets so we can do that type
of analysis across the genome now I'm
going to move very quickly to a
description of the network and I'm going
to change the view we know it has this
type of structure but I think it's
easier to read so I'm going to change
the view to this and let me walk you
through this rearrangement of the
network we can start here these are the
pre micro rna's these are transcripts
but get process to produce micro rna's
so here I'm showing a set of micro rna's
that do not induce fuzzy RNA production
to the right I'm showing the micro RNAs
that do trigger fuzzy RNA production
from this pasillo site I said that the
Perdue produced Vasilisa can in turn
trigger secondary production of small
RNAs from ordered transcripts shown here
and the resulting fuzzy RNAs and also if
you remember I said I had a set for
which I have no time no trigger so this
corresponds to all the fussy producing
regions that do not for which I have no
target and at the bottom are all the
target transcripts for each set now if
you were wondering what kind of genes
are involved in this network again I did
a functional enrichment analysis and
also before we go through all the
categories I can summarize this in a
simple statement most categories are
represented in this network and actually
this result triggered another question
that I thought it was I think it's
pretty interesting we
instead of looking for categories that
are enriched because everything is there
one can think of what is not there so
with lead we did an analysis for
functional under-representation and
there's only one category that is
underrepresented my network that
corresponds to genes involved in
translational regulation and actually I
don't have a hypothesis for this I think
it's very interesting but I don't know I
have no way to explain it at the moment
anyone has any idea I'll be happy to
hear your thoughts so we have perform
other structural analysis on the
networks that I don't have the time to
discuss today but if you're interested
and happy to tell you about it now we're
just going to move on to the second
objective which involves determining the
regulatory contribution of the network
so this is a summary of the network
components I've gone through most of
them before I just want to stress the
fact that my network includes about 20%
of all known auravie Dobbs's genes which
should be indicative of the overall
potential but when you think about it
it's not only the regulatory potential
of this network it's not only not only
involve the genes that are there but
also their activities an example would
be if my networks involve regulation of
a transcription factor the transcription
factor activity would play into this so
that's the first thing we did we started
asking what kind of genes are here and
we first look for transcription factors
and here I'm highlighting in red all the
transcription factors found in our
networks the summary is that there's 25
26 percent of all transcription factors
are on there small RNA regulation
according to our model we can broaden
this search by just trying to search all
genes involved in regulation and this is
a result about 30% of all genes that
have been involved or I've been shown to
be involved in transcription regulation
are on the small RNA control
so in summary when it comes to the
contribution or the regulatory
Constabulary 5% of all describe jeans
most function with categories are
represented and about 39 about 30% of
all genes involved in transcriptional
regulation appeared to be under the
smaller name control now you might be
wondering how can we use this met
regulatory meta Network remember I use
this I use a composite data set to
produce this and one example that may
refer to plant pathology is you can ask
the same question I was doing before but
for defense response genes so again if
we look for all the genes that have
function related to defense 30 percent
are under small RNA regulation so an
example here could be if you have your
system where your pathogen is disrupting
the regulation or the regulation of your
favorite host gene either up regulated
it down regulated and you want to
understand the mechanism at which this
is happening you can use this model to
ask first it's Eugene on the small RNA
regulation and if it is where in the
network is it how many small RNAs are
targeting it so there's some useful
information you can get from it but
there's also I want to show very quickly
and this is the last part of my talk I
want to show how I want to do it so back
to my plan first was to produce a model
network which I've done then step two
involves having
expression data to produce now simple
specific networks so moving from a meta
network to something that corresponds to
a plant or a symbol or a treatment so
I'm going to show this is based on
preliminary data and I'm going to use an
example using an uninfected plant so if
you remember I have RNAs and a small RNA
data set from all my samples here is a
summary of an rna-seq experiment where
on the x-axis I thought all the Express
genes there are about 17,000 my
libraries
and on the y-axis I'm showing the
expressions the expression level as the
log of the normalized count so there's
just a lot of libraries but each one of
these corresponds to a specific gene
this would be the section of low
expression genes this will corresponds
to high express genes now from a network
we know which ones are on there smaller
and a control which I'm going to
highlight here in red so about 35% of
all the genes have the potential to be
regulated by small RNAs now if you
remember these interactions makes sense
if both molecules are expressed you need
the small RNA and the transcript for
regulation to occur so I'm not going to
show it but I did the same analysis for
small RNAs and then I can take all the
data and input it into my model Network
so here I'm highlighting in red all the
nodes that show expression in an
uninfected sample you can't really see
the black dots because the network is so
dense but those will corresponds to the
non Express genes and now I'm gonna take
away everything that is not expressed in
this particular sample and this is what
you're left with so you're gonna notice
here there's a bunch of free nodes this
corresponds to transcripts for which the
small RNA is not present or vice versa
so there will be no regulatory
contribution here but if you look
there's still some edges so all the
edges are still exist in this network
corresponds to instances in which the
small RNA and the transcripts are
detected as expressed in my in an
uninfected sample so again I'm gonna
change the view so something more
friendly here is a method network here
it's the network corresponding to my
uninfected sample so I suspect that it
corresponds to us much smaller subset of
all the nodes and interactions but this
ones would be the ones that are relevant
so with this example I hope that you can
imagine how we can use this to evaluate
virus infection virus effect on
regulation so our plan is to produce
this type of sample specific networks
and then start asking what are the
changes are the structural changes
and also I'm showing this as an on and
off state but they're also there's a
quantitative side to this so you can
also query or ask what kind of genes are
undergoing expression differences or
differential gene expression and where
do they fit in this networks and how
viruses can affect this smaller innate
revelatory contribution so my
conclusions so you can take a breath in
that I think I'll finish with this I
just want to say that for my thesis
project and this process this project
what I did was to construct the model
network of a smaller in a regulatory
global regulation I confirmed the
accuracy of my approach and illustrated
how it expands in previous reports I've
validated the regulatory potential
smaller in a mediated networks this is
basically going back to those big claims
about smaller and a being massive
regulators of gene expression now we
have data to support that claim and I
think it's true I develop a ban from
Mike's tool that it can be used for
other species giving some requirements
the tool can be thought of as a Hungry
tool this means that the more data
becomes available we can add that data
and update our model to get better
resolution the tool is not publicly
available yet and we're not sure whether
we're going to pursue a publication for
it but if you're interested we can apply
it to other systems and most importantly
we finally develop a model system that
can be used to study the role of small
RNAs in viral pathogenesis or your
favorite topic actually so for future
directions I think it should be clear
that what we want to do is use this
resulting model to determine the role of
small RNA mediated networks in viral
photo Genesis basically and also what is
the effect of viral silencing
suppressors and holes smaller in a
mediated networks which will be involved
asking what is the role of small RNAs in
this phenotype development and I would
just
to finish with acknowledgments I
especially want to thank Keith for
sticking up with me for five years it's
been a great time I really enjoy the lab
I particularly enjoyed the opportunity
of pursuing a project of my design and
interest just just seemed far-fetched at
the beginning but it was a great
experience I'd also like to thank all
the my committee members for their
advice and support mark Fuchs dr. Faye
and Chris Myers I especially want to
thank my lab members so Jeremy is not
here today but he's been a great person
to have in the lab he knows a lot of it
he knows a lot and he's very useful
hitter a lab technician also thank you
for the support and for keeping us
honest in the lab there's been a set of
series of undergrads that have helped in
different projects are also like to
thank Andrew Grimson and Stefanie Watson
which is undergoing a grad student in a
new green stone slab that helped us
during the development of small RNA
libraries and also Julia Brevard
self-injure ruined gene giovannini slab
that assisted us in developing or
establishing the library making
technologies and finally there's also
funny sources for this work most of
these were involved in the set of virus
related projects that I described at the
beginning and my network's project was
been partly funded by cats
so with that like to thank you for your
attention and take your questions
[Applause]
questions I'm wondering how you take all
of these different data sets all
together at work in a way that you would
seem like to be completely sure that you
have the pathway correct I think when
you put it in your network you have to
see of all of those parts in the same
sample so like for one sample for what
tissue sample you would have an S RNA
library and RNA stick library megiddo
library and make sure that you see all
of the parts that you need to see when
you use this larger set of libraries how
does that are you taking that into
account or how are you dealing with that
to make sure that all the parts are in
the right place right time okay I feel
let me see if I understand it's just to
recapitulate the question is how do I
know that my method network is
representative of a network that would
occur in a single sample thing is it if
you identify from gravitas as fruits and
you find a cleavage but you're my
earning and then smaller days are shoots
it's not really relevant right and so
this would I'll go back to you this
figure here yeah so or actually maybe
this one here
if for this regulatory for the recollect
area effect you occurred you need the
small RNA in a transcript to be present
at the same time and here all the free
notes so this is a network for an
uninfected sample so it represents one
treatment and actually represents a
tissue so we're dealing with tissue
averages all the free nodes in this
network corresponds to instances in
which one of the two in the pair is not
present so if we don't see expression we
don't make a connection when we evaluate
it in a single library right now another
thing you can consider is they also have
to be pressing in the same cell or
something like that but well actually
that's not entirely true they're not
cell autonomous so they can move around
I think that using the approach of
tissue averages is okay now even if we
have both nodes expressing us in the
same tissue library we don't know well
actually I'm not trying to evaluate
cleavage per library I'm evaluating
expression and the way we're going to
use this is in a comparative form so if
I produce this type of network in an
uninfected an infected sample I can see
how the dynamics change so I can see I
would be able to see if a micro RNA
expression goes up and its target
correspondingly goes down this would
correspond that were corresponds to
meaningful interactions so I mostly most
of the downstream analysis would be
based on that I'm looking at the
dynamics of each pair upon different
treatments yeah I understand that I'm
just about alright so the reference
network is just a map of interactions
and they don't necessarily exist in any
given plant and sometimes they may never
be present so one could think that some
of these nodes never occurred but this
is showing the overall regulatory
potential when
we look at expression then we see which
ones are active and which ones are not
the issue is that we when we started we
were planning to do and network /
treatment and we realized that the
results are not comparable we need a
model network because if you have a
fancy law so there is on it has very
very low expression you may not detect
it at all
so our aim was to get all the map all
the interactions map and then input
expression data to do it whether whether
they any different those that this
protected my production or the curve
shirt between the wear words in fact in
fact see that where the drivers family
interactions are called the big
syntactic my adoption order or the
tradition will show the loose I'll yeah
so this is a good question and this is
actually what we plan to do now because
if you think about a virus acting so I
mentioned that viruses in code silencing
suppressors and sinuses suppressors will
affect the production of small RNAs so
in a virus setting you may be preventing
the production of these micro RNAs over
here if you block the production of
micronus over here you may lose all the
downstream regulation and that would be
I mean this a lot of potential genes
involved in this so that's what we're
heading we don't have the data yet we're
working on that but yeah we won't really
want to know how viruses will change the
structure and we know they can target
each step interest of time I think I
will ask you to thank Jose and anyone
who's interested in discussing it
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu